for the last three months this type of
civil unrest has become the norm as
demonstrators protest ongoing
kidnappings and violence
as well as mostly stagnant wages in the
face of soaring inflation
protesters in port-au-prince say life is
becoming unattainable and they're
demanding that government officials do
more to address the problems facing them
on a daily basis
traders can't take to the streets our
children can't go to school because of
the kidnapping and crime rising costs
and inflation are only making things
worse for us
everything from food to fuel is getting
more expensive
bakeries that make the bread most
stations rely on every day could soon be
forced to shut down due to supply
shortages and rising costs
the war in ukraine has hurt us a lot
because imported flour plays such an
important role it has made it difficult
to get wheat into haiti that's why it's
so expensive for us even if we can't
afford it
haiti imports 70 of its food and the u.n
estimates that nearly half of the
population is in urgent need of
assistance
many of the medical workers who went on
strike earlier this month over security
concerns are refusing to return to work
until their wages are increased
we're aware that we're not supposed to
hold the strike for this long but it's
not our fault we've tried talking to the
government but they tell us they're not
able to increase our wages
haiti's most vulnerable are the ones
paying the highest cost as there are no
doctors or nurses to attend to their
needs
there were eight patients here with me
five already left the hospital with
infections because they couldn't find a
doctor we are asking the government to
solve the problems of the strikers
because we cannot suffer too much
anymore
the political paralysis in haiti has
only gotten worse since the july
assassination of former president
jovenel moyes
no date has yet been set for new
elections and the acting prime minister
says the first step is to hold a
constitutional referendum
tuesday protests marks the 35th
anniversary of haiti's current
constitution
and organizers say they will continue to
apply pressure until those in charge
move forward with a change the country
so desperately needs
teresa